[Music]
alright ladies and gents it's that time
turn up your speakers strap on a smile
it's the sins and here's your host Adam
let go
[Music]
Wow holy crap
after throwback right there that is the
voice of Ellis Williams former employee
of Legion report who went to a booth and
audio booth and recorded that man we
thought that was hilarious for a while
so funny and now it sounds right
alright so this is it Sims left Co
fender ik Nikki G on the ones and twos
woody on the hair and makeup and
wardrobe and everybody feeling good
thousands of questions thousands like
like our Instagram DMS on the top right
hand corner it says 99 plus top which
means that's too many to count in terms
of like requests that we haven't talked
to yet right and then hundreds more in
the DMS right
I had a few hundred of my own DM yeah
Twitter was crazy I mean you added them
all up yep it was a lot I appreciate the
support everybody as Instagram and
Twitter over the last few days of course
josh has send me a few things but I've
had so many people comment to me about
the positivity of the comments in the in
Twitter and Instagram and I looked at a
lot of them and I I mean for somebody
who doesn't like the social platforms
and they hate all the time you did go
through a phase where you were very anti
Twitter because you just thought it was
all mean yes I did I thought it was all
mean people and I just want to thanks to
all the Sims and left go fans out there
it is it's special it really is you guys
are special I wouldn't be looked at this
way if it weren't for you guys I think
it's all part I'm gonna try my best not
to cry for this podcast you're still
feeling those emotions I am well woody
got me going and when she was doing my
makeup so she's already made me cry
twice in the last 10 days and now she
started again and I'm like trying to say
I'm trying to take deep breaths
no and I don't want to look at your face
because your upper lip can get
I'm out Monday I'm here for you but
thank you it's a celebration
no I know I know it's a great thing
that's very sad cuz Bleacher Report's a
special place it really is and this room
what we did in this room with a special
right right even going back to when we
had cars driving out of our ears in the
old office and like buses that was like
the same traffic pattern I want to back
does everybody realizes the same [ __ ]
cars behind us every day of the good
days I'm going to get on Instagram at
some point here soon something my best
friend I don't know if it's gonna I'm
hoping it's not me having to man this
down I'm hoping that NBC got a my job
rendering my hope is that is that is
that this company you're going to really
believe that you're the social media
made I'm going to spam the comments of
your Instagram so hard every post I'm
gonna be commenting up a storm alright
so how are we doing this today okay so
here's how this is gonna go again Josh
did a lot of work as he's done for the
show the entire time so I pulled a bunch
of questions so as Adam mentioned we got
thousands of questions first of all a
lot of you have things off-limits today
nothing is on that day but I am the
filters okay it's not gonna get too
aggressive a lot of you asked if Julian
Edelman is a Hall of Famer
that was in Monday's podcast this week
so go back and listen to it there we did
a whole debate about it a lot of you
asked for advice on starting a podcast
that was in the mailbag that we did the
week before the Super Bowl yeah I went
deep into that so we're not gonna do
that okay
but I have pulled a bunch of questions
for today about the current NFL history
Sims personal stuff left go personal
stuff podcast topics a whole bunch so
I'm just gonna go down the list we're
gonna go for about an hour and a half an
hour and 20 sure and then we'll see
where we're at at the end of the day I
really didn't know this is a 12:30 so I
would like to do something right
beforehand we took this down off the
wall it's been a talk of a lot of people
it says at Sims left go stop cursing
ripping it was a reminder for fender ik
to us to not curse as much yeah Sims
I'll let you do the ceremonial ripping
of the stop cursing sheet day and this
is specifically from Joanne Arella
joey gunz yeah that's really the one
that was concerned about very upset of
our culture
I love you Joe but [ __ ] this sheet of
paper
sorry joey gunz so anything goes today
so first question coming up from a young
man by the name of Trent Taylor
tragically for Adam left go left go
gonna get a bro tattoo on his ankle now
as a farewell to say oh do me and you
need to get tattoos together so we get
it instead of the W on your ankle we get
s and L would you consider it and what
would you want the tat to be no I would
not what would you want it to be oh I
would want damned if it could be
anything bowl of rice and beans
no daddy cigar yes daddy cigar I want it
to be a daddy cigar that you like put
our initials into it that's a good one
or into the smoke coming off of I'm not
I'm not I am NOT canceling out a chance
of a some sort of tattoo my tattoo you
sorry that I have okay are meaningful to
me and brought to my life the long horn
right yeah my the wood with the W and
Kyle Shanahan and rod Beiber's who I
don't even talk to anymore Montrell
flowers who I don't talk to anymore yeah
Bose Cape is the only one I talked to
you but I don't care because it was a
very meaningful part of my life and they
are they're my boys for you're trying to
shoot memento - are you just gonna be
completely tatted out well I'm not and
of course I have my kids my family's
initials are you saying you want some
Adam left go on your body I'm not I'm
saying that at some point in my life B R
or a microphone with an Adam left go on
there something likes a left go P R
right let's fill your entire back let's
make this a marketing opportunity and
you know what I'll say this if he were
to do that I would probably be in be
careful I know I'm not saying definitely
I'll talk it with the Bruce and Sharon
left oh that's a big thing all right
next question
in the Jewish all right next question
Brandon more big fan of the show and
would like to thank Sims for his
football wisdom and knowledge best
wishes in your future endeavors thanks
BAE I would like and this is for both of
you okay what is your favorite Aaron
Rogers throw or moment favorite throw I
know the throw that came to my mind
right away and it's the play that didn't
even count it was the play against the
Chicago Bears where like he stepped up
in the pocket and then rolled right and
he got lifted off the ground by I think
Hakeem Hicks oh this you know I think
was two years ago and he still through
it like 45 yards on a line while being
sacked in the air and he got called for
a holding right it was just a play that
it reminded me of that mahomes play this
year against the Niners where he like
scrambled around and threw it and like
he skipped and there's just some throws
that you look at and go that's just
incredible I know and then for me the
other one will be the Detroit Lions Hail
Mary yeah it was so freakin high it was
on national drive and the game was only
through its seventy something yard and
the Packers season was about to be over
remember that's a 49-yard thrower you
know 70 is pretty damn good your
favorite thrower moment oh gosh I had
like four throws go through my head real
quick and I'm gonna hit him first of all
Game one I think about 2016 season they
were in Jacksonville he had two feet off
the ground why Jalen Ramsey was trying
to sack him and he threw a post to her
touchdown
the Cowboys playoff game where he
scrambles left right stops then
continues to run left and on the run
throws at 40 yards on the line to Jared
Cook a foot out of bounds so he could
get both feet inbounds that but I think
the number one to me and it's probably
like you got to go back there and look
at it is the Super Bowl touchdown pass
he had down the middle where it was
covered - and Ryan Clark was the
backside safety and I've heard Brian
Clark talk about it where he saw it was
coming and there was nothing he could do
because Rodgers threw a piss missile
right through everybody and that would
probably be the one that stands out to
me more than any because that was a game
where they didn't run a whole lot of
cool plays or anything it was just
Rogers throwing dimes I have one more
yeah the throw to beat the Cowboys not
the throw that set up the field goal
when he rolled left and threw it 40
yards crossbody - Jared Cook falling out
of bounds did you just say that one but
I was gonna say the other one was this
from the game - when he threw the riser
it for the touchdown
-
Devante atoms that went right by the
corners head and the ball facing the
left at left corner in the game - yes I
think I loved both of the rows I knew
you said that one yeah sure he wasn't
listening to me I know I saw that
Charles would since out of the SPN I say
what's up more quick Aaron Rodgers
question from Jake's alley if Sims is
going to NBC will he pledge for the rest
of Aaron Rodgers career he will sing the
Aaron Rodgers song every time he plays
in primetime no doubt about that good I
am going well I got a they done they
didn't love that I sang that on the
primetime oh you got talking today well
they didn't feel like the audience knew
me or knew that gig yet which I
understand right fix that so I got to
fix that hopefully people get to know me
but any time I go and oh Aaron Rodgers
always gonna do that I've also are you
guys into I broke out you know my
deshaun Watson a lot last week and he's
a fan of it - Sean one no it's so
[ __ ] awesome
you said that on television I did I said
the freakin and then go my homie my
homie my homie my homie he came he came
out with a new logo my homie my art girl
one of our big fans Anastasio Williams
sent me the schedule for the Chiefs next
year and how they play
Patrick mahomes is going up against like
every quarterback that I love he's going
up against he gets to play Andrew Luck
in the Colts again which is gonna be
awesome they're playing the Packers next
year so there's gonna be my home's Aaron
Rodgers it's gonna be kind of Patriots
again they're also playing the Texans
so you're getting mahomes watson right
he's also playing Jacksonville against
Wright to see that matchup again I am
very excited you see and veiled his new
logo today did you see that and then he
was also told he can't play basketball
just the best quarterback in the NFL no
absolutely not no PR get your friends to
record you playing basketball against
random dudes at the gym and then
everyone's gonna say how athletic you
are that's the new thing hey listen I
thought the the the compiled looked at
the play that he may had the nice play
there was a lot of cultural diversity on
the floor I have no problem with no kind
of level on there just saying yes
saying it's a little off co PR yeah
darius Geiss is doing left Co PR right
now is he once a week he's releasing a
workout video it's a very smart move
alright guys next question here from
Patrick Erlich this one is for Chris I
played high school football and the snap
count was down set hut every single time
maybe a hut hut every now and then when
I listen to a game broadcast and you
could hear the quarterback snap count I
can't for the life of me figure out how
anybody knows when the ball is gonna be
snapped right it sounds like white 80
white 80 blah blah right that's what my
little boy says and I'm like WTF yeah
how do they distinguish going on one or
two consider give any insight into the
cadence and how offensive players more
specifically the center in linemen learn
how to decipher sure well yeah you learn
how to decipher it over reps and getting
a feel for the guy's voice and his
cadence and how he does it in general
right so that's going to help out the
offensive linemen in general first of
all with the snap count you're free to
really use any number I mean color
number you want but there's going to be
live colors like black could mean we're
going on three right black 88 black
Getty eight said hot hot but that you
might just use it just the black part to
get people to go oh it's on three might
be read as a live color if I say red it
means we're audible it's truly a new
play
but in general it's going to be booty
five blue 85 and within that the next
thing that's gonna come is set hut and
you almost want to say it together
that's what they're saying when you hear
Brady he's going ahead and because he's
trying to say it almost in one flowing
word because the offense is going to
snap the ball on set they're gonna snap
it on set to get off the ball just a
hair earlier cuz they're snapping the
ball so that's what you're hearing and
that's why it sounds so muddled at times
my little boy had the same issue it I
was like no they're saying said he would
go like I was like yeah do that because
the defense isn't gonna go on set but if
they just went Hut right well they can
just jump that first word but yes
they're not gonna go on set it's just
another way to have one word almost one
word even though it's two different
words that flow is give Hut right I
don't know I've always thought Hut's
come before hikes
I always thought his hut hut hike I
think it's I think it's just a it's I
never
hat hi he had the lower-left Hut like
could I could I literally say could I
say but no would be like but born like
you hi killer used to it yeah you could
say whatever then why is why do you
think hut Universal no I just looked it
up I don't know what that this is
according to the Guardian it is a the
term comes from a famous player of the
Notre Dame team of the 1890s Jeff Hudson
oh yeah the difference between the D and
the T being impossible to spot as the
players went on to play with other teams
it seemed they continued to call hudhud
so the term just became the football
that's fun now it just either learned a
lot on this ice hut sounds better going
on to and then with all of this you can
change it up so you can go on set hut
you can go on first sound you can go on
you can go on first sound so first down
so I'm pretty might get up there just go
blue and it's a snap they're gonna love
it alright you might go second color
blue t5 and you say that again like a
huddle you'll say that in the huddle
it's like a lot to think about but then
I look at a huddle sometimes Sims and I
don't see everybody being that like that
listening that hard know sometimes I got
like a person like a heads out there
because not everybody has to hear the
whole play right really the only guy
that needs to know the whole play is the
quarterback everybody else is just
listening to their a little part of the
play right all the receivers but I mean
but don't they need to know whether it's
black or blue yeah and a lot of times
though in those situations they'll start
to say it they have code words as they
break the huddle so Brady might go you
know you know we've heard Peyton Manning
used tiger and Phil 1 & 2 when he said
Tiger it meant it was on 1 if he said
phil was on 2 with dick and balls that
was another one for 1 & 2 Sunday Monday
Tuesday might be on 3 all these things
so they might he might call I go 72 you
because you change them gained the game
and he's going to know you're not gonna
change them and we'll paint and go
through a whole season with so no no no
he's gonna have something else for sure
for sure if he feels like he's using it
too much he's probably gonna use it as a
decoy at some point and tell everybody
Tiger Tiger
yeah I'm just afraid of confusing my own
team yeah well those are things you go
through through the week and hopefully
when you start to change things up we're
at the point where it's comfortable and
I just think that one guard turns around
and goes are we going on balls or
Tuesday and it's like okay we're a mess
all those linemen are pretty good enough
they're pretty smart guys they're
yeah yeah all right next question here
from our good friend rod Simba great I
actually love this question if the NFL
had a loan system like there is in
soccer allowing players under contract
with their original team to play for
another team for one season what player
would you like to see dealt to a
different team next so pull up the teams
think about something they come back and
they come back to their original team
right I'm gonna purposely I have to pull
up the team one tyree kill on Aaron
Rodgers team right off I'm purposely a
viable Patriots and Aaron Rodgers the
Jaguars let me thank ya so you would
take Aaron Rodgers and put him somewhere
else versus giving someone too high all
right good I said Tyree killed that this
is very true the podcast I'd love to see
Blake bortles as a starting quarterback
of the Patriots and see if they could
win the Super Bowl
like I really like like Belichick left
go PR you want to show everybody how
great of a coach you are you in a ring
with Blake bortles they will build a
statue in front of the Lincoln Memorial
like they'll block the Lincoln Memorial
with you that's how incredible what
you've done it's not a bad thought hold
on we miss anybody else yeah we anyone
you'd want to give to Kyle I would love
to see Odell Beckham jr. with Kyle that
would be one for sure I'm glad you said
that
yeah yes Odell wuji throwing it I'd love
to see Aaron Donnell and the Bears and
see what happens if Khalil McNamara and
Donna are on the scene right right yeah
I thought about that like or even Khalil
Mack on the Rams with Aaron Donald and
sue and this is gonna sound crazy
I'd like Phillip Rivers on the Giants
Eli's not going anywhere I just want to
see a quarterback battle between the two
guys that were traded for each other in
2004 both fighting for their end of the
careers to be the starting quarterback
of the Giants both I like chaos throwing
comebacks that take four seconds to get
there yeah anybody else yeah there's so
many it ends up you always like I would
like to move Julio to anywhere else like
I would like to put I'd like to put
Julio back on the Niners I'd like to put
Julio in Green Bay all right not that
everything wrong with that Lin I just
want him on a new team where someone's
like how do we use this guy yeah yeah
good answers anyone else otherwise I'll
move on no I think that's it all right
let's go to the next one this this name
sake Quan on the Chiefs would be amazing
not that they need any more office of
talent find out all right next question
here Oh Del's name came up this question
is from Ryan Chimel with Odell having
missed substantial portions of several
seasons do we have to reconsider if he
is still in the conversation for best
wide receiver in the league yeah I mean
I think it's hey listen he was not the
best wide receiver in football this year
I mean there's no way you know to argue
that you know again at the end of the
year I do think that Odell probably
could have came back if it was dire
straits and their team was still
fighting for something but they probably
were like let's not work that's not
worth it let's not risk it but certainly
I've been a little bit of an issue for
Odell and I didn't even think Odell last
year was totally Odell anyways with his
aunt coming off his ankle injury I am
expecting to see the sixth gear totally
back in full force this year for the
2019 season I thought that if you were
having a real discussion about just 2018
and who the top wide receivers were
right you're gonna argue with me on some
of these I believe that the conversation
was tyree kill DeAndre Hopkins yeah
Julio Jones er I'm just looking at the
guys that I really think are really up
there for the number one spot right Tony
Brown but I'm also gonna put juju out
there as if we're really in this debate
sure because it's weird I look at the
Mike Evans the world I don't know and I
will also say that Michael Thomas was in
the discussion for the year he had right
no it was not that for if we're putting
2018 into a vacuum right as the top
receiver performances he was in the
discussion for that Odell had moments
yeah I thought there were a few games
where it was like all Odell or bust like
that one game where they almost came
back against the Falcons it was all yes
the game against the Jaguars to start
the year right he showed out right but
it wasn't consistent but I think the
question is fair it's it's why I'm
realistic about Carson Wentz right now
is that durability is a thing right and
that I want to see it consistently but I
also think that it was extenuating
circumstances with the injury how the
season ended starting off one and
whatever it was it but look we don't
make those excuses for the other guys I
mean Tyree Kill was the best receiver in
football okay what was I talking about
with Stefon Diggs and we were in the
back he was just he was like yeah that's
the best receiver in football this year
he's like I mean to have those yards and
he had you know 17 yards forget I do
think again Mike Evans needs to be in
that conversation yeah I just want to
say their team's not that good so I
watched Mike Evans extensively right yep
I just felt like so many of his stats
came after the game was decided that I
kind of knocked those guys down a notch
yeah okay sure I get that other thing
I'll say to everybody out there with the
receiver position and this will go back
to Julian Edelman who's a legend or even
Michael Thomas that way you know I'm not
gonna sit here and just go oh my gosh he
ran a slant route that the coach made up
and he wrote three steps that he turned
around and the ball hit him in the
numbers he's definitely one of the best
receivers in football cuz he can do
three steps and then slant and catch the
ball
is this your is this your stoner pro
football that is so you know again stats
can lie to you that way plus two on that
play that's where you just got to be
careful of how you evaluate the wide
receiver position just for the the guys
out there but I think we hit all the
crucial names I'm glad that you've come
around on Hopkins though yes Hopkins had
an amazing last two years it's really
special
I think Hopkins you know I don't hold
him quite as high regard as you do but
he's right there I mean he deserves to
be in that conversation he does yeah I
believe he deserves to be in the
conversation but I but I don't think
anyone would disagree that no one does
more with less than Tyree kill yeah it
could be a 70 yard touchdown on any play
but I can't say that about anybody else
no and what he does for the rest of the
team yes that's what's amazing
all right guys next question here from
Justin Baker for Simms if left go were
to get hired on to an NFL coaching staff
I love it what position group would he
have the most success coaching oh that's
a good one so for this one I just
started thinking what
position does he know the most about
right who would he be able to
communicate with best right which
players would not just intimidate the
crap out of him yeah I don't know if
left going the D lineman would get along
yeah yeah no I just were my brain yeah I
hear you there I actually think of this
is the easy one
I mean this is actually really easy
exactly right I mean George Kittel
specifically told me that nobody has
deemed him more this year than Adam
lefke stalker alert he's the one that
usually starts the conversation Arnold
has said the same thing so you're
becoming a stage 9 clinger okay just got
to watch out for that listen but no
again Kelsey you have great rapport with
these guys right there so they also have
that wide receiver like energy - they do
like they're both like I like to pop
bond right but I'm also smart with my
finance and you don't even be get like
too technical at the tight end position
you'd have to learn a little bit about
technique of blocking first video all
right fellas sometimes we're catching
sometimes were block are you Rosner you
know Rosner the coach over here yeah I
have no doubt about that
you think it's Titus and well I you know
I always keep my contacts going yeah cuz
sometimes you're the host and sometimes
you're the left co-host get it
co-host chairs about to be empty next
week things are popping on my yeah
follow me to NBC alright guys next
question here from Ralph del Sarto good
luck Sims gonna miss you on the pod can
you guys around
Edie Reed and Troy Polamalu players and
is Polamalu a lock next year for Kenton
did you just yell bubble there I think
you blew a bubble was it about what I
thought it was a piece of can I break it
down into these yeah faster and reader
Troy Polamalu Troy Polamalu okay yeah
you you throw the ball deep and they're
tracking the play three scares you more
a dream you give the ball to a running
back and one of them meets him in the
hole ooh
it's really I'm gonna give it the Troy
Polamalu okay close you toss it to the
outside to a speed and that person's
tracking him to the sideline whoo
man I'm gonna give it to Polamalu again
okay I am you're throwing an out right
and it's a one-on-one tackling situation
on the sidelines at a dead stop yeah
it's still pretty good problem maybe
Edie there it's closed Troy
hold on I'm not done okay go ahead god
they intercept you yeah definitely ad
scared to death Edie ads go into the
house and I'm like oh gosh
cuz he's just not gonna go down at any
point he's gonna be thinking house the
whole time play is coming down the game
is coming down to one play and you're
the coach and you need you need a
game-changing play have you told me it
was a pass play I'm picking ed Reed if
you told me it's a first down play and I
don't know if it's gonna be run or pass
I'm gonna take Troy Polamalu
Wow I would break it down like this I
think in simplest terms these are both I
think the two best safeties I ever had a
really player prepare for I never got
Dawkins in his prime so no disrespect to
him but I would think these guys are a
little bit more versatile than dogs a
little bit more eye and I'm better in
the air than they were both awesome at
everything I always would say Edie Reid
was the best past defensive safety I
ever saw or studied against and Troy
Polamalu I thought was the best around
the line of scrimmage safety I ever
played or prepared against his blitzing
his disguising jumping over the pile
filling holes like that so nicely came
for the passing game Edie was a master
at disguising a master of knowing what
you like to do as an offense and he
could be real tricky that way I mean
don't both I mean Paloma was a
first-ballot hall-of-famer just like I'd
read in my eyes
I think what's awesome is like I would
love to have Belichick talk about both
of those yeah that would be amazing
because I know that his level of respect
for both of those guys is insane what I
love about both of those players is they
each did things that you didn't even
know were feasible right like the
jumping over the pile thing we've seen
Roy Williams do it to you we've seen
other instances of it but it never was
as impressive as when Polamalu did it he
would throw every ounce of his body at a
complete disregard yeah and his hair was
a movement right like not even the
commercials and the products and all
that stuff but to watch it it made him
look
you watched a guy that it looked like a
Tasmanian Devil it looked like somebody
put a helmet on somebody that is not
used to our culture and said get the
ball yeah and he put every ounce of his
being and Edie read to me was always
this Silent Assassin then he would hang
out with Ray Lewis and he didn't say a
lot and he kind of be back there but if
the ball touched Edie Reed's hand you
were screwed yeah like when he picked
off Kevin Cobb and returned in a hundred
and four yards against the Eagles as
soon as he caught it and I saw it was 20
I went Dan yeah the thing about Edie was
Polamalu was what a freak athlete that's
how I always came off to myself and read
was what a calculated cold-hearted
assassin yeah
but they both would get you they just it
just felt different ways and Edie Reid
also they both had a look you know the
visor and the all-black uniforms and in
skinny but also like nasty and then
Polamalu just flailing energy yes you
play Troy I didn't like have to actually
play I was back against EDI I played
against Ed I mean it's just a left coast
point I mean let you know he gets a hand
on the ball I threw it past a deep cross
to mark Mike Clayton and the ball was
high in his two hands though where he
extended his arms out and Ed got a hand
in there just stole it right out of his
hand my some of my favorite practices I
ever had were being Troy Polamalu
and Edie read when I was playing for the
Tennessee Titans
you played safety practice they knew
that I knew their movements and Sims
thing you're impersonating defense yeah
because I they knew I was you know just
that good of an in personality obsession
and Kerry Collins liked that I he
thought I had their body movements and
what they did pre-snap down and I got
the soul king right that read with his
shoulders hump just lurking in the
background like yeah over here then
Troy's like the Doug you said the
Tasmanian Devil at the line of scrimmage
like oh god she's blitzing oh god she's
coming back they were that was a lot of
fun doing that it was hard to take your
eyes off of either of them yeah and
that's why they're so damn spade they
definitely are alright guys next quarter
let's pull out the teams before as I
read this one question is from Matthew
Joe how many many Joe how many currents
starting quarterbacks could you beat in
a fight
how many currents starting quarterbacks
could you beat in a fight okay
so Holmes no Brady I'm gonna go no do
you think you could be Brady and I yes I
don't think I'd be Brady - fight - Sean
no Lamar no philip rivers no luck I feel
like I got a chance yeah I feel like I
could like go to him into like trusting
me he might be one of the strongest ones
yeah but I think that I could let go PR
I'm into turning his back and then death
gosh I only feel good about the old ones
well I can think I could like calm down
Mariota and then take advantage of I'd
have to fight dirty I feel like Tom drew
who's the quarterback of Miami nobody I
got them he got them drew Brees Eli
taking him down I don't think Rosen can
mess with me he's one of the young guys
I'm gonna get in there who else am I
missing Arnold I think I can car Sammy
Derrick card definitely I can beat up
Derek Carr I went through my mind
definitely with my mind this is so funny
oh gosh dak Prescott whooped my ass I'm
really afraid of Nick Mulla Nick Mullens
look at me me like I'm gonna take you
the Bayou pay those it's those four is
about where guys in Josh rose that's the
old guys and I can touch I could take
down Alex Smith right now yeah I thought
about rivers but rivers is feisty I
don't know solo do you take that bortles
he's not a starter I started calling
that one star trying to get me in
trouble yeah my bad hey what do you
think what would what would upset you
more if my next co-host was Blake
bortles right or major Applewhite oh I
don't think I'd care either way I'd go
either one's gonna be a disaster go
ahead there's a lot of people that
tweeted at me
yes major coming in and I was like a big
suggestion and what was really funny to
me is is like no I'm I'm legitimately
friends with Simms yeah I couldn't do
that because I wouldn't be able to like
you would you would understand why I did
it because you know that I'm always
trying to make fun of everything but I
also know that it would piss you off a
little bit well I mean I would I haven't
even thought about that but yeah sure he
might not give you a jacket on the
sideline now you better be careful
all right next question here from
Jarrett's self Jarrah itself yeah all
right you better say something is that
our former Jarrett
no okay that's Jarrett least why is it
so uncommon that head coaches have both
coach and GM duties like Beebe does it
simply come down to having someone with
a skill to do it or owners not believing
that someone could possibly handle both
I think it's I think there's been so
many instances over the years where it
didn't go well yeah the Chip Kelly's of
the world I mean no I mean Mike Holmgren
did it pretty well for a little bit of
time sure I don't think people realize
how special of a human you have to be to
take that off yeah I don't think people
realize that it's very hard to be a
player's
friend when you're in the locker room
and then look at him in a completely
different way in a callous way and then
not upsetting the locker room because as
a GM they're pieces as a coach they're
your players and I think one it takes
that it hasn't worked numerous times
yeah and I think it's also good to have
a balance of power like I think I don't
there's not many guys that are capable
is really my hands so that point were
you going to use Belichick has shown the
ability to cut and trade players right
but you always tell us that he's a
player's coach and yeah players I love
him because he can be he's honest with
them too so they know where they stand
but he is capable to like what Lefko
saying is going walking upstairs and now
being in the front office and putting
that on and going okay it's a business
decision time I can't worry about you
know how much I like this guy is a
player right I can promise you he loved
lawyer Milloy you know what I mean but
he let him go cuz he felt like it was
that time in his career right I think
the biggest thing is it's a lot that's
all there really is to it
you know guys like Bill Belichick they
didn't start out doing it this way
that's not the way it worked Bill
Parcells he didn't start out being the
GM Mike Shanahan didn't start out doing
that either right it's Mike Holmgren
same way it's about guys who to me the
ones that have been really successful
with it are guys who were really
successful head coaches they've mastered
that they've mastered the daily routine
and program and now they can handle the
extra workload of
being basically the GM and being that
guy but I was with the Josh McDaniels
who I would say is as smart as anybody
he he like hired a young GM and had to
help him out in a lot of ways and I feel
like that wore him out where he was
still trying to get his feet from being
a head coach but yet oh gosh I got a you
know go with some of these bumps in the
road with the young GM who's learning in
his way too and we want to make sure
we're on the same page right so it's
just a hard thing to do with the GM has
to know what kind of players the coach
wants to yes players wants to coach I
mean here you are if you're like you
know Sean McVeigh look at him I mean
he's going to the Superbowl he's not the
GM no because he's told les Snead what
he wants to he works on the game plan
les Snead works about worries about all
the little details but what you're
playing GM all the time and having to
handle some of that stuff
oh my right guard went down and now I
got to think about five replacements and
bringing them in to work out and do all
that you want to have somebody there
that can you can trust you and Belichick
has a lot of people around him like Nick
oh sorry oh no that's a well-oiled
machine and then you got stuff like the
Cowboys where they have an owner GM and
that provides its own problem right
because now they're going we have so
much marketing dollars into this one
player I don't know if we can move on
and it's gonna make us look bad if we
didn't nail that first yeah sure that
first-round pick and it kind of ruins
that I think as anyone can say it makes
it very hard to hold people accountable
because you're gonna want to cover your
ass and the reason Bill Belichick works
is he's not afraid to make mistakes
and and there's just not a lot of and
that's why I do give Robert Kraft more
credit I had a conversation last night
with master a writer here and he said
how do you break up the percentages of
the Patriots and this is what I came to
last night I'm giving Belichick 71%
right I'm giving Tom Brady 15% right I'm
giving Kraft 6 and that leaves me with
what it's 21 that's 93 and I'm giving 7
percent to every other player that's
played for the Patriots got you but
that's how I'm breaking it down right
because I believe that Kraft deserves
the 6 percent for giving the facilities
and backing off and and I just don't
think people realize how hard it is for
a billionaire to go I'm giving you the
keys to this and I'm not gonna
in this you know I think there's
something there's something to be said
for that there definitely yes that's why
it works but I'm giving Belichick 71%
yeah I mean I probably would've gone
higher
I had him originally at 82 and then I
was like but what about all the tile AWS
of the world like the players need to
execute so that was like my sure you 70
or 80 no all right next question here
from Matt Costello when did you watch
your boy that is my boy when did you
realize you had something special going
on with the podcast was there a moment
and interview a show I'd like to hear
Sims on this first I had one I can share
one to my head go ahead
the Martellus Bennett interview last
year when he said that he 3% blew up and
it was like on every television no 1% of
NFL players smoke weed and it was
everywhere and we looked at each other
and we were like okay all right good
interview I didn't have a moment like
that I just felt like I as I was walking
to the train on a daily basis I had like
guys coming up to me all the time saying
I love the pod I felt like that's when I
was like oh this we've kind of people
something yet people are listening it's
creating a little buzz and people are
following it that was kind of like my
moments for me my two that came up one
was when the New York Post when Romo
replaced your dad right wrote an article
about you talking about it and he
labeled us as left Co and Sims perhaps
that was when I was like that's when I
was like we didn't even push this out
yeah and the post just took this and ran
with it right and then the other time
would be just when I started reading
Instagram DMS from like people in like
Dubai and they were like I don't think
you understand what your podcast means
to me like I still get those now and
dude it's been overwhelming
yeah like to all the people that have
been in our DMS or the people that are
messaging me and they're like yo we [ __ ]
with you you're the man like we love you
guys like you gave me enough confidence
to do our own like reading seeing that
we have an impact that's when it hits me
because just a word to everybody I don't
care about views I don't care about
numbers like all that stuff is [ __ ]
like all I really care about is like
when we went they
and we met people in Atlanta and I got
to hang out with him that's the real
[ __ ] yeah because that's the only people
that I really a mess with so that's the
that's what it me when I realized my
next question here from Luke declar
which podcaster would survive the
longest in the woods Bear Grylls style
Josh left go or Sims I think this is an
easy answer so three of us in the woods
Bear Grylls style you like camp or
anything Josh I yeah I mean I think the
answer for this reason Sims will
eventually go I'm not eating a gecko we
have to find brown rice and beans also
he's an OCD germaphobe I don't think
being out in the wilderness is really
your things actually people are the ones
that are dirty not the wilderness of the
three of us I would last the least and
I'm happy to say that I need the most
and I believe that Josh growing up being
a survivor fan yeah has probably like
long days without food on purpose
to prepare himself just in case I get on
the show I would be good with the Flint
the machete if you gave that to me to
start a fire I could definitely do that
though I like adventure trips yeah I do
that you know with my family every
couple years scrape the magnesium then
you smack it with the machete yeah some
tinder in there just to get it going I
know I also know how to fish with a
Hawaiian sling so if you give me one of
those I get out there round the elbow
slingshot bring home a shark and we're
waiting for a couple days so yeah we're
all good winner what is a Hawaiian sling
it's what they used to fish on Survivor
where it's basically like a spear with a
elastic band on the end of it and you
put it around your elbow in the water so
that it's like creates torque and then
you let it go the band comes off your
elbow and the spear shoots gotcha yeah
if you're like over a reef god you can
easily get fish that I would just throw
it and hit him I just do that you would
just throw the spear but you're
underwater you can't I'd get a jump or
missiles in the water apply with Spears
underwater okay next question you win
survivor
wow that was some intense stuff right
there what's that I'm not going into a
pool with Josh ever yeah just Google
Hawaiian sling okay next question here
from Matt Hill how will Adam GaSe and
his offensive system affect Sam
Darnell's development well I mean I
don't
anything but positives for Sam Darnell
but Adam GaSe Adam GaSe is like one of
those guys that you know I know we've
talked about it before where he lives it
with the quarterback I mean he is like
loyal to a fault with his quarterbacks
and and making sure that the game win or
lose especially lose doesn't get blamed
on them I mean I think he does a
phenomenal job of not only managing the
quarterback but managing the numbers and
situations to where the fan base doesn't
have a jumping off point and I think
it's one of the reasons he got fired in
Miami is because he constantly sticked
stuck up for Ryan Tannehill and the
things he did there and of course they
weren't happy but I would say you know
just between that the results he had but
NL they were pretty impressive when you
really look at it and then what he did
with Cutler in Chicago and what he did
in Denver with Peyton Manning whether
good bad at the end or even Tim Tebow he
just has an understanding of how to make
it work for a quarterback and then you
want to add back your boy I'm excited
turtle I'm excited to turn on Adam GaSe
when Simms leaves telling you Monday is
gonna be wild I'm starting a whole new
list of rivals and villains know I think
that look what I I when I briefly talked
to Sam about I know he was excited after
meeting Adam GaSe so I know that they're
getting along early I hope that Adam
GaSe feels like he has a lot to prove I
also know that he's gonna be on the
shortest lease he's ever had I know he's
a new coach of the Jets but let's also
think realistically he went out of Miami
and had a lot of change in a short
amount of time
yeah not saying that it wasn't warranted
or that it wasn't the right thing to do
but that's now a cloud that's gonna
follow him because the perception is he
didn't get along with strong personality
players and in New York they're gonna be
it was not deemed a good hire when it
happened I'm not saying it's not a good
hire but I'm looking at it from the
media's perspective which means they're
gonna be very critical his press
conference was not great it caused a lot
of issues for a lot of people he became
a meme that's not what you want now I'm
hoping and from everything that you said
I have a lot of faith in gays and I
believe that gays throughout his time in
Miami had some very interesting play
calls for some very bad quarterbacks
that one games they shouldn't you
shouldn't beat the Bears in Miami with
Brock Osweiler he did you shouldn't beat
the Patriots in Miami with a Tannehill
and they did with Jonah's gray or
whoever that wasn't running back so he's
done some amazing things he didn't play
Kenyan Drake as much as he should have I
have a huge issue with that if I'm just
being honest but Miami seems to have
been a very extenuating circumstance but
I look at what he can do up here in the
New York Jets I think they have some
pieces I think you have Jamal Adams that
looks good you have Leonard Williams
that looks good I think Tremaine Johnson
will have a better year this year I look
at that offensive line I think they need
some help they need pass rushers but I
think for your boy that there's gonna be
a lot of pressure on him early and
that's that's why I wonder how long he's
gonna have because mechag ninh is on the
is on the hook right now right like he
has to win right now so I'm looking at
him more as like the outside pressures
on him he controls his future if him and
Sam get it off and they get a few more
weapons underneath I think they can do
it but he's gonna have a lot of pressure
because it was a weird offseason for him
I have sees do me cool alright the most
competition Bellatrix ever had as far as
coaches in the buffalo and josh allen
and what they got going on there and yep
Flores done in Miami yeah it's gonna be
the first time he's got true three games
he's gonna have to worry about the
coaches are on their X's another
absolute because Flores is good to know
what Belichick wants to do GaSe has a
pretty good idea of how to attack that
defense every now and then and then the
Buffalo man Patriots always have trouble
in half alone yeah
alright guys next question do you agree
with what I said there what's that did
you agree you said 90 million things I
know on the next question we call the
breakdown of the [ __ ] whole
organization all that's aligned the
status of the media in Miami and New
York holy [ __ ]
well I'm fascinated yes shut up next
question and I'm hoping you guys
disagree coming to you first on this yes
please one quarterback to build your
team around for the next five years five
years I'm gonna take Patrick Mahone the
greatest quarterback in the NFL
but it's not this year it wasn't last
year but yes for the next five years yes
Rogers has hit that age where it's going
to go down to a degree he's gonna be
able to pull off the same magic oh oh
hey just say it keeping a real Wow Pat
mahomes was the best quarterback we've
ever seen I thought you were saving that
for one day or touch this you've become
such a shock jock he said five years I
know you're saying he's the best you've
ever seen he's played one year and
you're saying he's the best you've ever
seen when you can evaluate talent yes
it's all about pivoting I like to self
Scout right all right you stay hard and
true none of the things I think I think
that Kansas City probably wins if Rogers
is the quarterback wow wow what a missed
wide open touchdown pass first yes Pat
mahomes didn't stop a third and 10 no he
would have no you he would didn't get
there because Aaron Rodgers under
through an out against Seattle on
Thursday night couldn't hand that's
right and then his team punted it didn't
let him go for a listen and then the
fourth down he's magic I don't know what
say I can't believe you you're such an
anti mahomes I can't believe you don't
like Patrick Mohammed I love them you
know that
all right guys next question and just
for everyone listening there was just a
pound in the middle of the table after
details Caleb what is Sims workout plan
I'm a CrossFit guy look like pretty much
I go in I'd warm hot like CrossFit gyms
like you treat you do right I just I go
in and I warm up I do not start lifting
weights until I'm like totally sweating
so like I will I'm the guy at the gym
where people are like oh you got a good
workout in already and I'm like no I
just warmed up I haven't even started
like cuz I I have issues with my body so
I don't want to do anything like hard
right off the bat but I might it's easy
I do legs and core every time I'm in the
weight room no matter what I'm going to
do legs and core and then I'm going to
either do a push or a pull for my upper
body or legs where are you sprinting no
I mean I'm always gonna do I'm like
let's just say I get warm I get going I
start doing core I'm gonna do some I'm
gonna squat right and probably superset
it with like sled pulls to go along with
it superset what does that mean like I'm
gonna get done with this
and walk right over to the sled of Golda
sled and I get done with the sled and do
50 abs something like that do that a few
times around and then change the
exercises up to where then all of a
sudden maybe I go leg extensions with
trap bar deadlift and I'm gonna put the
core in there and then I'm gonna go okay
now it's time for a push or whatever it
may be and I might do dumbbell bench
with something else
legs superset involved in it - protein
shake when you wrap it all up always
like Morgaine V vegan protein shake
always you guys have seen me drink that
a million times
left go any thoughts on your workout
plan you want to add current workout
print planache my boy Donovan and I go
in there and I go kick my ass for an
hour yeah because I don't want to be
here and I need you to kick my ass
here's my money right and beat the [ __ ]
out of me and I'll be back tomorrow
that's a start that's the way that's the
only way I can't because I'm not like
you I like you I will say this when I go
to the gym afterwards I go that was
great so happy I did that I released all
that stuff that was awesome right but if
I can convince myself to just like go
and get a cappuccino yeah have a little
daddy cigar and bring a journal and just
get my ideas out that's my day yeah
that's my day you you don't have to
listen to music when you workout do you
I will show you this moment can you be
in reality well the problem is is I go
to a gym where there's music so if I
don't listen to my music I'm now
listening to techno and I don't like to
workout to techno right I like to
workout to Rick Ross I like to workout
with angry people cuz I would all I work
out to 50 cent I wish I would it'll be
angry I wish you were at the gym with me
when I went to the equinox in California
in August and he's out there running
wind sprints on the basketball court by
himself just a giant blonde guy no I
will say this I do enjoy going to a
basketball court and running suicides
and then shooting and then running
because then I'm like hey at least I
worked on my shot no no doubt it's great
that's a suicides or that's that's great
stuff I I yeah I I'm I don't listen to
anything yeah you just do it I don't
listen to music when you work out you
don't listen to music ever no I which is
when I'm in the car or if I'm on the
train or the plane really yeah that's
kind of where it goes you don't listen
alone I just like you say you like angry
I like angry - I just talked to myself
angry
I just got you [ __ ] do you really more
for the game no be great be great yeah
yeah great yourself as I start to go
that kind of motive see I need people
that are talking about how great they
are so on the opposite you're like you
suck and I need like 2 Chainz to be like
threw myself a surprise party let's go I
probably need to do that alright
everything I listen to is about how dope
I am I would recommend that to everybody
the next question here from giants life
one for Sims did you always want to do
the podcast or did bleacher report make
you Oh Laura's yours right away what I
would say the opposite the actual
opposite I don't think bleach or thought
this is gonna work no I don't think
bleacher who are giving you the only
reason we did this pod podcast is
because of the two guys in this room
specifically starting with Josh vendrick
yeah who said we need to do a podcast
then Adam started to go you're right and
then that's why if you go back and
listen to the early episodes I always
called it the [ __ ] podcast you hated
do it yes right well because I just felt
like it was extra on my day Simmons
would always do this we just talked
about the NFL for five hours why are we
gonna do a podcast and we would always
tell them because we're gonna build
something yeah because if we keep doing
it we're giving it to people and then
eventually they're gonna listen to it
they're gonna like yeah you guys were
right about that for sure I know but
that was the day where I was doing like
25 videos a day right so we would make
you do it
logically all again but just in a
continuous hour and a half versus a
minute so I was like oh my gosh but I
get it and good thing you guys made me
do it and we made you book yes at that
time too oh yeah that was text your
friends on here yeah if they text you
and say that Rogers is in right like
that we're doing that here gonna wear a
bag over your head so yeah
totally it's not Chris okay next
question from Adam Tara you get no
jurisdiction over Aaron Rodgers anymore
Patrick bones is your guy go hold on
that's a left go I don't share my
opinions about football in this pockets
no one wants that
next question from Adam
if you were a high school recruit now
where do you think young Sims would go
oh gosh right Babson hmm yeah Clemson
would be pretty tempting gosh of course
Nick Saban would be tempting hold I just
gotta think about my miss I mean listen
both the teams now that I've matured and
this is gonna sound like a Homer thing
you're gonna say Texas again no that's
going to say that Rutgers Michigan has
always be towards the top of my list but
not with that guy as the head coach
there so that's off the list okay Notre
Dame Notre Dame I know I sound like I'm
a homer you are such a high no but I've
gotten to that age it's weird
where's he owns you where you see when
you're there and you see that Stadium
and fan base the fan base and the first
marching band in the history of our
country and they tell me Joe Montana and
this school of course is a phenomenal
school and great alumni base I always
look at that like I text my wife
sometimes when I'm there I really hope
that can go to school here one Monday
really if Philip plays football I would
love for him to play football at Notre
Dame was there ever even a second where
you thought about going to Morehead
State absolutely not
what about Rutgers Rutgers like I really
wanted to entertain it yeah I did but we
didn't well they were my senior year in
high 11 Oh an 11 right about Syracuse no
they never really got in the mix with me
I mean I got some letters from them and
things like that you know I always was I
always thought of like you know really
would my Miami was amazing and when I
went on my visit there I had a lot of
fun in Miami and loved it there was just
one thing that bothered me about my
facilities not even NASA like that yeah
like they only fill out the stadium when
it's a big game that's bad you know what
I mean if it's somebody then just you
know I always see that comes down it's
just not the College atmosphere I was
looking at we're in the Big East when
you were being recruited they were they
were the Big East
I always thought that Florida State was
dope yeah I did you guys I've always
I've always thought that it would be you
could you could become like the best
quarterback ever there right like you're
competing with like the Charley wards
and the Jameis Winston's and stuff at
the Chris wank ease but that's also an
area that country I wouldn't want to
live no I think that's the would be the
thing to
I mean you go that that a pair report
and it's like the most depressing
airport ever yeah see
I've just sat there before and it's like
there's nothing here yeah but yeah USC I
mean that always I never would really
entertain that going out all the way
across country like but to play in that
Stadium yeah and USC is a special I mean
that's come on
USC Notre Dame Michigan you know who
else we miss it in that conversation I
mean those three alone are just like
such pillars of Congo LSU yeah Alice we
would be cools you got all the athletes
for sure right and what are you
competing with Alabama yeah boy yeah but
I mean you wanna be on that stage no but
yeah you're about legacy you're in an
incredible stage a lot of those SEC
schools
alright guys next question here from CJ
East which non quarterback would you
pick to build a franchise around in the
NFL hmm can't pick a quarterback pull up
the players I would progress I mean it
to me right away
Aaron Donald comes to my come out a
bunch of hawks I thought that you were
in the Fletcher Cox above Aaron Don yeah
I think maybe Aaron Donald's youth might
make me choose him guess a little before
a Fletcher car okay but hold on there's
some others I'm missing too you know
we're going right to the d-line I think
I am I do I think Dean line I always
kind of go quarterback okay no
quarterback in this conversation I even
thought about some tackles offensive
line type of guys cuz you're you know
you find the right one you really can't
go wrong with that
I mean if you get Quentin Nelson you go
damn I got him for 10 years yeah like
he's gonna be really good but I would
probably go with Aaron Donald
Aaron Donald proved a lot to me even in
these playoffs you can put you could put
Mack in there - yeah Mack would be very
close in that conversation other
thoughts left go it's interesting like
you know you knock you're not gonna
build around a Tyree kill you know build
around rice like a say Kwan writing like
that right there I don't know if there
is one left tackle in the NFL right now
that's that much better no I agree
there's a lot of good one I feel like
that whole era of the Terron Armstead
Tyron smith the
that got Williams with Washington yeah
yeah great left tackle yeah I feel like
they're hitting the inside you're right
and so we're there's there aren't really
any great left tackle right
Lane Johnson you know is up there for
like the other tackle but you know make
quitting Nelson's one of those guys Zach
Martin's one of those guys that you know
is gonna be there
but I don't know if it's that important
to start a franchise around yeah but
Aaron Donald could ruin a game Kaleo
Matt could ruin a game Fletcher Cox is a
little bit older than them right he can
ruin a game right is there a super
amazing pass rusher yeah I don't know I
know Mike I think about like mom's a
little older right so we went with
Khalil that's the guy right over there I
thought about a Myles Garrett he's close
to that or he's very close to that as
well he's not disruptive his Arenado
back right now there's no linebacker
that blows me away no and I don't know
if a Derwin James or so like that is
that import a piezo Maul Adams and Erwin
James are up dose of the position that
you know they're gonna be involved in
plays on every play base you know how a
lot much of safety position yeah I mean
that's that's not bad I honestly think
that would be as far as the positions
you would look at be one of the first
ones you'd go okay safe he's got to be
involved in the run game you helping the
past games got a quarterback the defense
a little bit it's very very important
alright next question here from Teddy
Swenson if you had to build a team
around Brady moss and Welker or Brady
Edelman and grok who would you choose
and why
3d moss and Welker Brady Edelman and
Gronk yeah baby Moss Welker Brady
Edelman so whoa the big thing there is
you have the two slot guys yeah Welker
or Edelman who would you take of those
two I'm going to take Edelman it's
really close but I do think Edelman who
is quicker out of their cuts um in their
private yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna say
Welker might have been a hair quicker I
would say that you could make the
argument down to this yeah Wes Welker is
most famous play in the Super Bowl as a
drop right Edelman has three sheriff
credible plays in the Superbowl that
were incredible catches he's been super
reliant yes I feel like
Edelman's
or durable than Welker was I feel like
he's lasted longer than Welker was but I
felt well curse maybe ceiling was higher
than Edelman ceiling in terms of
elusiveness and playmaker yeah I mean we
also didn't get a lot of it because he
was in Miami you know he's he was more
durable than I think if you just really
think about his career I mean he came up
there you know I think that where iya
Edelman might not be quite as quick as
Welker in his prime but he's bigger he's
stronger big he has better straightaway
speed you know and maybe yes a little
bit more durable over the middle kind of
like to what you're saying to Welker got
the benefit of really being the first
guy to have like this position invented
around him to where he benefited from
that - both awesome legends so I would
go Edelman over Welker in that
department now in moss and grind rock
and their prime is it their prime or is
it when they played for the Patriots
yeah I guess I would argue that Gronk
and Edelman have made have been more
important to the Patriots than Moss and
well kurz run yes but the the height of
the moss and Welker run was higher than
the grunt it was only two two years it
was really only one yeah because Brady
got hurt in 2008 we just never seen
anything like that yeah that was special
oh man 23 touchdowns so I think for the
purposes of this question we should say
when they were with the Patriots I'm
going with Gronk and Edelman okay yeah
and Brady I think that Gronk is the best
tight end of all time and I think that I
can I think that Edelman and Welker is
really really close right and if we're
going just the Patriots run the
longevity of Gronk and Edelman yeah but
the NFL had never seen yet what moss and
Welker doing that year that was
incredible Darrelle Revis and it was
just it was in bad feel like the
Warriors like that season felt like the
Warriors when they won 83 gaps all right
next question here guys we actually had
one fan who submitted audio so I'm just
gonna play the audio this for you Wow
so here we go a wrap
[Music]
[Music]
it's time when the Sims and left coaster
back in time and all G homies no
National Signing Day just passed now
tell me which five Sims the Left Cove
guests would you give five-star love you
fellas now see po Nelson who right now
is the face of NHL Network and MLB
Network awesome doing play-by-play of
the NHL all-star game and it's he's the
man he's a heavy hitter I would say this
I thought backed up anymore either now
I'm married I would say and tell me if
you agree with this yeah in terms of top
five humans that you've met right Steven
Nelson is up there he is up there
talking about just like all-around
amazing guy silky smooth to the point
where I want him to be more of an
[ __ ]
I mean one of the first guys that text
me when he heard the news they're like
yeah I mean he's just Johnny
professional all the way through so top
five guests Sims and left go so you can
just throw some names Phil Simms was in
the top five okay Michael Vick Michael
Vick because he was on episode 103 I
think three it was the day after the
Jets lost to the Steelers on Monday
Night Football and he said I'm pissed
about that [ __ ] game last yes and
then him coming on radio row week and
that blew up Michael Vick's in there
deidre Salva has to be in New Jersey
Elba has to be a match in faux pas pants
that was that was a moment where shout
out to Paul Kaplan still can't believe
you showed up yeah yeah like nobody knew
blind for the old teabagger Paul Kaplan
Pam so that leaves two open slots James
II drew salba Michael Vick
okay great so who are two the two other
around at the top five throw out some
other ones right or who are some ones
that we had repeat we got to get the
repeat guys like love repeat guys all
right let me
I feel like Oh Josh is putting a blanket
on think of this I thought like ice
cream Marshall came on more than one ice
cube was a lot of fun he was yes
I mean JJ Watt was amazing last week
yeah I know there's there's a lot on
Miller on a couple times yeah I had two
Shawn Watson on a couple times Kelsey
Derwin James on I'm trying to get the
old guys Ryan holiday is obviously up
there for me that was a lot of Phillip
Rivers came into the office yeah rivers
hour was incredible Oh Revis pretty damn
good they're all Revis was pretty much
it Jalen Ramsey this year was I think
when I got one like just because I felt
like I knew what we had said about the
Jaguars and things I'm going to say that
you cannot tell the story of Sims and
Lefko without Chris garden I'm just
saying I know it's controversial right
but that was a seminal moment on the
podcast you want to tell what happened
please carton came I get his name right
it would be good but he must not be that
important because a great card thank you
well the Craig carton
oh and Nicky G says Dan Levitt Arden so
seriously that was awesome no doubt for
sure that's definite so wait hold on
yeah Phil Simms michael vick yep idris
elba teachers elbow eleven thirteen two
dots and now we need the fifth one
that's where I kinda wanna do Craig
Curtin we can't put the story is what
isn't like the first carton came in
maybe the third month and he just [ __ ]
all over me yeah told me that if I was
still doing this in a year that I had
failed he was also holding a mic like
this when he was afterwards he felt
really bad in Texas yeah and he was like
you got 25,000 square feet in midtown
Manhattan you got a bunch of nerds here
who care about how Maria Sharapova is
doing in Wimbledon he did what is going
on here he didn't believe the office
gave just nominated didi Gregorius as
well
one of the best things I've ever done
that is awesome you lost I was awesome
that really was yeah that was a good one
I saw you know I'll put Dede on there
because it was like your birth it was
like around your birthday was you had no
idea was nominated and you literally
lost your [ __ ] yeah I feel like I'm
we're missing somebody I feel so many
yeah podcast number is this for us yeah
if you had to guess that's a good
question I mean we so I mean I literally
told Josh that we should stop doing
numbers because I was realizing we were
only calling the Wednesday podcast like
number and we were up to like 200 but we
had done all these other podcasts that
didn't count right so if you added all
of them up I would say we're around like
eight nine hundred maybe a thousand I
would think so we stopped counting at
episode 164 and if you like multiplied
that by three right that's any
multiplied it again by three you'd get
to nine hundred yeah yes I feel like
we're around there okay next question
here guys from Robbie Parker Sims what
NBA players were you cool with and what
players that you have beef beef with or
other NFL players have beef with did you
hang out so you did not play your the
start of your career in an NBA city no I
did not I was around like Richard
Jefferson a lot back in the day oh you
were big Nets fence yes Richard
Jefferson certainly would have been
around where Jersey in New York like
when I would come home in the offseason
he knew kind of one of the club guys
that I knew here in the city got it so I
would say that would be like the number
one NBA guy I was probably around at
that point and that was like you know
right before the you know the [ __ ] kid
came to town right it was right around
there right maybe right before that
right got it anyone you had beef with in
the NBA that you can share Kobe
so yeah but nothing nothing that I can
think of I remember being around the
walton kids a little bit but no beef
with anybody you know what's crazy is
you know another guy that was couldn't
have been a nicer NBA guy to me and got
I'm blanking on his Jason Williams the
one that shot him the one guy the Little
Giant and
yeah that's what's so incredible about
Jason Williams as there's three jason
williams and they're all so different ya
know he's the guy from the New Jersey
Nets Nets okay shot my accident and then
covered it up yeah then you have white
chocolate Jason Williams and then
there's another Jason Duke yes who I was
in Jersey high school the same year I
was with so my story about Jason
Williams the net that shot the guy yeah
is when I visited Syracuse I didn't get
into new house right away and I was like
all upset and I remember going to campus
with my dad and this is my relationship
my dad he was like we could either go to
the general studies meeting or we could
go to the new house meeting yeah and he
looked at me he goes if you don't get a
new house in a year I'm pulling you out
of school anyway so we're going to the
new house meeting and we went in there
and he looked around and I'm pretty sure
he looked at me he was like [ __ ] all
these [ __ ] we gonna kick their
ass and I was like [ __ ] yeah we are dad
like that was how I entered school and
so on the tour ain't so much so on the
tour of new house they're like does
anybody want to try and do like a live
shot like a pretend live shot I'm
freshman I'm 18 my brother goes my
brother would like to and I'm like what
so they have me go out there and it's
about Jason Williams and I'm standing in
front of a freight fate courthouse on a
green screen and I'm going I'm standing
here in front of a courthouse where
Jason Williams whatever and the guy
looks at me he goes are you broadcast
journalism and my brother goes he didn't
get into new house and I was like and
they're like why are you here and I'm
like cuz I'm gonna be here yeah yeah
that was in Jason Williams I'll never
forget like a regular Rudy of Syracuse
I'm gonna be here one day so I'm here
he's my guy all right next question here
from sad Giants fan for Kris over the
course of your career which defensive
coordinator was the most difficult to
prepare for and I'm gonna add in your
Patriots coaching days for this because
I know that you had to make tapes to
help with scouting right yes definitely
was yeah when you add that in right off
the bat I can tell you for sure
that Rex Ryan was very annoying to
prepare for okay the first time I to do
that for the for the New England
Patriots and we had a play Ryan and that
was the rival of the the New England
Patriots it was a definite vibe in the
building when
we were getting ready to play the New
York Jets and in dealing with his
defenses and all the moving parts and
the coverage disguises and all those
things man that was tough um I'm trying
to think of some other ones just back in
my day
yeah when you played yeah I mean Gregg
Williams at the time I was playing when
he was the D coordinator of the
Washington Redskins like you know that
was a really crazy aggressive you hack a
fence right where you really had to be
on your P's and Q's to stop the bullets
is and all the different motifs similar
those two defenses yeah both of those
guys go we're gonna win the game with
our d4 yes no doubt call a different
game when you'd right right I mean I got
a little taste of your guy Jimmy Johnson
holy quit I was only like a rookie and
dealing with that but that was that was
a pain in the ass he was amazing and I'm
just trying to think if there's anybody
else but I would say those are the ones
that jump out to me more than any gotcha
all right guys we're gonna go about 15
more million from buddy Ryan yeah sure
so that's why it's so funny no doubt
with the Houston Oilers right and I'm
trying to think if there's anybody else
out there I'm missing you know gosh I
got wrecks when I was in Tampa one year
and he was a D coordinator the Ravens so
that was annoying go ahead I'm not go
next question here let's go we're gonna
come to you first on this all the teams
Sam Berryman which new head coach has
the best chance of making the playoffs
next year my bet would be Freddie
kitchens
new head coach best chance of making the
playoffs and Sam our guy is betting on
Freddie kitchen all right so rundown who
the new coaches are yeah Cleveland Miami
Denver Cincinnati just those teams right
off the bat the Jets of course are in
that conversation I'm just trying to go
to the NFC now Tampa Bay ok Aryans yep
Arizona of course with Kliff Kingsbury
Green Bay with Matt Lafleur ok right
it's for me of those that's it I think
for me it's Denver Green Bay yeah
because I look at Denver with Vic Fangio
with Mike Munchak on the staff it's a
very adult staff with a lot of athletes
still on the defensive side of the ball
I wonder what they're gonna do for pass
catchers but Cortland Sutton got a lot
of
perience I like Philip Lindsay I think
they could get a lot out of keenham if
he's the guy right it's just an adult
team and it's a good home-field
advantage
yeah the problem is is they're in the
AFC West so it's Chargers and cheese
right the Packers are the one that makes
the most sense because they have the
best quarterback out of all those teams
yeah and it's it's about you know
keeping pet and keeping the consistency
on defense and going what are we gonna
get out of Aaron Rodgers with an actual
office well the other one it's either
quarterbacks that need to make a leap in
their second year or don't have one yeah
and I just don't have faithful on those
team yeah I think it's those two you
mentioned in Cleveland that would be the
three I would break it down to right
away yeah I think Cleveland is poised to
be in a run but I guess if you maybe
just go you got to pick one right I'm
going to pick Green Bay just because I
think they kept Mike Pettine and I like
what he did with the defensive side of
the ball like him best quarterback in
the NFL yeah with that with that and
Rogers and all that I like that
combination what he said the second-best
quarterback
oh nice are you texting I'm not texting
anyone else getting the next question
pulled up so the question here is from
Tyler Smith Stovall we can do this one
really quickly the question is is that
dude going to shave his eyebrow so why
so what mr. DM me the other day we last
1,000 and you just remind everyone what
the bet was well I thought the bet was
before the year that he knew Blake jar
win' and that was his guy and he said
over/under thirty five catches right for
the season right with 30 by that was the
number thirty-five was the number of
thousand percent right and he said he'd
shave off his eyebrows and that if he
went over thirty-five he got to come to
the studio and come on the podcast
he made a furious run yes so would
master diem does the other day and he
said haven't forgotten about our bet I
have school and interviews for
internships this is wrong but I promise
I will be getting to the shaving as soon
as I am finished with all of that and I
think that's fair so that was two weeks
ago
then he DM dust on Monday can I be the
new Sims I'll shave both eyebrows a lot
of disclaimers there a lot of
disclaimers I mean school and interviews
what's that have to do anything can you
imagine showing up to a job interview
with half an eyebrow and saying that you
bet on Blake jar win to have 35 catches
this year and
that's why I showed up at an interview
with 20 stitches in my lip and said hire
me when was that when I went my first
broadcasting gig with Fox Sports 1 I was
playing in a four-on-four league in
Southie Boston and I took an elbow to
the face as a guy Ranger down he was
coming right at me and my friend pushed
him from behind
right and he this guy lost his balance
and as he was doing that it's elbow
caught me right here yeah and I had to
go do a Fox Sports thing with I would
say that's a better excuse than betting
on Blake jar wins to catch over-under
but yes you got the job as the as the
arbiter of the homies and and someone
that's gonna keep this thing going would
Rangemaster
I'm sorry we're gonna need those
eyebrows and so you can do your
interviews but if you will continue to
be a member of the homies I will direct
everyone into your page to follow but
we're gonna need at some line rather
those eyebrows wasn't one it was one one
just saying hey go to you're a legend
you go one your film Blake Jarvan you go
down and you go dead hard all right guys
next question here from Josh Duggan am I
the only one who thinks of Simms wife
when a Ray Liotta chantix commercial
comes on I will say you are not the only
one Ray Liotta didn't Danielle go on a
date with him yes she did and she's like
still mad at her dad that her dad even
let him let her go out on the date with
him because she's like what kind of dad
did I have that she I'm just so happy
that he's finally done smoking yeah he's
done he kicked it he's killed it how
does it go in your house when that
commercial comes on I always look at her
and we look at each other and laugh or
whatever like it's I mean if I was her
husband yeah every time I come on I go
Karen that's all we had she really just
really watched Goodfellas like for the
first time like six or seven weeks ago
right where she was like you know I've
never really sat down and watched as you
watch it together yeah I don't give a
damn I know you don't know whatever it's
cool so good when he's freaking out
about the helicopters the senior they're
laughing about funny how like it
really is a phenomenal the best part
about it is when I was growing up and we
used to go to Jupiter Florida to the
beach right we used to go to the Jupiter
Florida wasn't that in the movie to end
they got there like hanging out they go
so but either way I go to this Beach and
it's a nice Beach and Ray Liotta used to
be there all the time with two different
girls every day every day and it was
just funny that it went for full circle
my wife was one of those girls just
dropped a lie
all right next question here from will
Haas can you ask sims to wax poetic ly
about playing against Seneca Wallace in
college one more time for me please no
Hoss is this a guy I was he from Texas
and you know I know a will huh anything
you want to say about Seneca Wallace
gosh there's not a lot to wax poetic ly
about I mean I think he came to play us
a Texas one year and he was in the
conversation for the Heisman and he went
like six for 24 in the game Seneca was a
talented guy certainly I mean a guy that
was kind of dual threat that way could
throw the ball really well he was really
at that time the only legit guy on Iowa
State but they were like outmatched when
they had to play teams like us or
Oklahoma to where they were like a real
force I was aware though I want someone
to find the footage of who was the guy
that was the quarterback of Indiana that
then went on Antoine Randall L right I
want to find the video of Antwaan Randle
playing quarterback at Indiana yeah
those are the guys that I want to see
the guys that became like like Hines
Ward at Georgia sure I haven't seen
enough video of that yeah cuz I want to
see like when I saw Julian Edelman at
Kent State right it's the most fun cut
like football video you're gonna see cuz
it's a guy that takes over the game by
himself because he's not that great of a
thrower it's so much fun yeah Randall L
was definitely exciting I don't think
Hines played quarterback at Georgia I
feel like he had he might have been a
high school quarterback but I'm pretty
sure he was a receiver I could be wrong
on that I don't know I feel like he
threw some throws yeah I'm sure he did
all right we got this question from a
bunch of people the gentleman five one
six Jonathan with so I'm just gonna
throw this out there
Simms what is your favorite memory from
working at bleep Airport and left go
what is your favorite memory of working
with Sims at Bleacher Poe oh gosh so
we've got the podcast we
got the draft we've got yes us hanging
out on left coast roof looking at the
great view that's up there yeah okay
that was good that was good I mean I'm
really a lot of my mom one of the first
parties at Simpsons house with everybody
game ever right you weren't there yet
and canvasser heard me talking about
Eric Ebron he looked at me and he goes
you're just stealing all sums of [ __ ]
and I was like it was like the beginning
of reselling his stuff but come on the
number one moment I will always remember
Wow Noah Jam pool Oh more can we release
this video today he'll give us consent
Noah Jeff are you sure the same day that
I gave my cell phone to a homeless guy
any football related moments Scott try
California I was gonna say that up there
for me is the Golden Gate Bridge episode
that never came out that whole trip was
a management was fun um I oh how about
how about Malcolm Butler intercepting
the pass in the Super Bowl versed in the
lobby of the old bleacher report and he
intercepted the Seahawks like we're
gonna dam the Seahawks are about to win
the Superbowl all-star and we were just
like wow and no one was actually there
running around like a psycho like those
are ones that jump out to me the first
time I met you before the Denver Seattle
Super Bowl that was fun
that was um gosh there's so many the
drafts were great too they work I think
I thought they were great and I'm gonna
still be doing stuff with Miller and
your honor and all those guys but I
thought those reached a point where
super cool they were and then just all
the athletes that we got to that we got
to just mess with definitely gonna be
like welcome to the Thunderdome damn we
need to release the know again pool
video alright alright guys couple more
here before we wrap up big smooth
Sims who was the craziest part er
partier that you have ever been around
in the locker room player or coach Josh
and if you don't want to share I
understand but well let me think about
that real quick just it's gonna be my
Tampa Bay Buccaneers teams that I was on
I mean that defense you know for a lack
of a better phrase just had some strim
you know gangsters and I don't mean that
like literally gangsters like they
walking around with guns and drugs in
their pocket and like Oh mess with me or
I'll shoot you but they were just badass
dude they were just badass dudes who
were like it's football and when
football is over we have fun and when
it's fun's over we go back to football
and it's the pedal of the metal all the
time you know to where yeah of course my
man Dwight Smith is in that conversation
with me I mean we had so many just great
moments together Ronde barbers in that
moment together and not that everybody
was always some guys just drank some
guys just smoke some guys did both
whatever it may be
yeah but that team had some
personalities on it where I almost you
know I feel like Gruden and the team
like that the defense was that way they
wanted their defend a to play better
yeah renegades that way if it's a reason
we were the Buccaneers armaiti Markell
fools just got traded to the Magic City
Wow okay all right guys two more here my
biggest partyer probably Matt Matt off
in college that guy got after it guys
two more questions here first one real
quick from James Lamanna yo Sims can I
get one more stupid little left go all
right guys and then the last question
that we're gonna wrap it up here this
one is from sure Owen de Visser and I am
definitely botching that name hi Chris
for the last podcast any tips for me
when I take your spot on the show next
to left go best of luck with NBC from
your own to Visser in bodegraven Holland
so this guy is gonna come to America
take sim spot and he just wants to know
he's from Holland isn't that weird
American Idol for that seat is gonna be
the value here's a thing like OPR that
guy right there is coming here to take
your song it's fine it'll be one of the
money I'm just saying that as someone
that understands real estate right the
value of that seat couldn't be higher in
this studio and I'm just saying yeah to
all the people out there right we might
have to Kelly Ripa this Kelly Ripa we
might have to see who has enough right
to take that seat yes right now it's
Sims and left Co right it's gonna be
somebody in love right somebody in left
as you can hear a man from Holland do
you know you what you have to do is come
work hard and deal with a lot of hot air
from Adam left Co and if you can deal
with that hot air and those diva
qualities then you'll have a successful
relationship just like we did Rodgers
and left 15 years until Patrick's can
yeah I love with his symbol that here at
least now no it was not my favorite and
I I love Patrick mahomes of course but
yeah so yeah it's uh I don't know it's
not as cool as T b12 Russell Wilson's
well P and M don't really go to oh it's
a bad I feel I feel like it looks like
an Avengers thing almost it's like Iron
Man with the Kansas City yeah that's
okay yeah I just I don't know alright
guys that's all I got that's yeah that's
it that's it for the mailbag before I
pass it back to you and I will just
share some of my own personal news that
next week is actually going to be my
last week at bleach report as well
I have also accepted a new job so I am
leaving left go all alone here at least
report it's just me in the home is just
left going the homie so yeah I'm trading
in my 33 are you gonna have 66 now I
think that I think the homies will
always have 33 I mean you're gonna hold
on it now I'm gonna hold on a 66 when I
fill that somebody write it whoever I
have in the chair they need to bring
their 33 yeah cuz I'm bringing my 33 the
homies will bring in their 33 and the
whoever is in that chairs got the 33
Josh do you want to share where what
you're doing no but I want to say this
is this will be the only time I will get
emotional so I always do this before I
genuinely mean this when I say that Josh
was responsible sometimes for more of
this than even us yeah that know that we
are both you are a head in the sand
person and I am a crazy emotional person
right and Josh is the functioning member
that kind of keeps it all together
definitely josh is one of the most
incredible people I've ever been around
yeah he's one of my best friends and no
matter what he does in life I know he
will be successful because when I tell
you that if Sims were to have gotten a
GM job he would have taken Josh to of
ran operations he's not exaggerating ah
this is not a friend buddy thing right
there are and at josh is 27 years old
right the the whole 40 homies were
insane he's 27 yeah josh is a 55 year
old man going on 20 70s well the most
impressive people I've ever met and what
we built was when you got DMS in the in
the Instagram it was me and Josh like
and Josh is the one that I think took an
Instagram handle from nothing and made
it 30-something thousand yeah right and
so I will never ever ever take credit
for things that Josh did you're [ __ ]
amazing I praise you are you're one of
the most consistent humans I've ever met
my entire life no doubt about it I mean
you don't get the nickname Johnny Google
document unless you're special like it
you know I mean because you were yeah I
called you that because you were always
on your game I can always count on Josh
vendrick having all his crap together on
every single day with a goal in plan
keeping me and left go on the straight
and narrow getting the show everything
all the details all set up Josh is a
superstar in his own right just like
Adam left go is left go is the man and
going to go on to still kill the podcast
and Turner TV and whatever else because
you're that talented but Josh on the
other end is going to be the guy that's
going to be the CEO at some point and it
would be awesome if Johnny Google
document became the CEO of Google just
be cool it would just be I want to say
this is an honest honest word to the
homies because it's a promise that I'll
make as I keep this going whether it's
social whether it's online and Josh
you're gonna come on as a guest sometime
in the future anytime at Sims we're
gonna have you back too but the number
one thing is is we didn't want to hold
this [ __ ] from anybody it hurt my heart
we would sit in rooms together and go
damn it we don't like we would honestly
not think about your wife for your
family or my family we only thought
about the homies because we'd sit in a
room and go I mean we don't want to lead
these people on yeah like you guys have
given us everything so when I tell you
that we've been trying to figure out a
way to do it gracefully we've genuinely
have right but there's no way but it was
kind of just reaching that point it was
great run and yeah I love you guys yeah
- doesn't mean we can't get the band
back together at some point he was
making the final toast I'll make it
since I'm on the way out the door and
Lefko is going to be here y'all have
plenty but either way I'm holding
champagne to a great show a great time
in our lives and great people that are
around us not just us three but a lot of
the people that help whether it was
Simms and left go to show the podcast
everything about it this was a special
time in our lives and I think we should
cheer to that and Cheer the future and
bigger and better president yeah Simms
that was a good toast
thank you that was pretty good I'm a dad
now some ships are made of wood chips
but the best ships are friendships and
that's what's up my friends you Franklin
they love that one oh yeah
so here's a deal I'm gonna be back meant
Monday and I'm gonna give you a little
taste of what could be coming and then
as we've mentioned before we have a
number of Hall of Fame interviews that
we're gonna have for you next week I
have a special conversation with Justin
Pugh my guy gives you a lot of
information that'll be next week and
then I'm gonna take a vacation I'm not
going anywhere for you and for my own
personal benefit yes I don't even know
who the post of my podcasts and all
that's going to be but either way you
could count on my big mouth in my
football studies coming coming out you
know in early March on NBC Sports and I
can't wait to roast your opinion through
this all right without I think we got
all day I got emotional before I walked
in yeah but I'm feeling I'm feeling
peaceful real champagne yeah I'm
thinking about what team we're all gonna
run in ten years yeah do we want to take
over the Giants now that's weird yeah
where we go we got other you have a good
time let's listen picky and choosey then
and American always beat Alliant can
move out this is the last one yeah for
Sims peace out homies I love you so much
for pendrick good evening everybody and
for the lef koe mad wheel holla holla
holla atcha later
[Music]